beef Wellington das vielleicht schwerste
Gericht der Welt ich habe mich schon
einmal daran versucht als ich für ein
Restaurantkritiker gekocht habe und da
ist einiges schief gegangen jetzt ist
einiges an Zeit vergangen heute will ich
mich noch mal daran versuchen ich will
alles was ich gelernt habe in den
letzten Jahren auf dieses eine Gericht
anwenden nicht umsonst ist beefellington
Gordon Ramsey signature dich das ist
einfach ein Gericht was für gutes kochen
und gute Kochkünste steht und ich bin
verdammt gespannt wie nahe ich an ein
gutes Ergebnis komme deshalb seid dabei
wenn ich mich am schwersten Gericht der
Welt Versuche der erste Schritt geht
unsere Bratensoße die unfassbar intensiv
ist schon fast wie ein Lack wenn Sie uns
denn gelingt als das für ein Restaurant
Kritiker gemacht hat war das der
springende Punkt der mich die Punkte
gekostet hat deshalb gebe ich dieser
Sache heute auch ganz viel
Aufmerksamkeit und lasse nichts
anbrennen hoffentlich im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes ich fange nämlich an mit
zweieinhalb Kilo Kalbsknochen ich bei
220 Grad im Ofen ordentlich Anröchte in
der Zwischenzeit das dauert so ungefähr
eine Stunde kann ich schon mal anfangen
Schalotten möhren Lauch Knollensellerie
ganz grob schneiden denn das geht gleich
gemeinsam in den breitet
[Musik]
eine Stunde später sieht das ganze so
aus mama mia wunderschöne braune Farbe
blubbert ist köchelt wir haben Unmengen
von Fett unten auf dem blechschwimmen
und da bleibt es auch wir werden das
schöne Fett leider nicht mit in den Topf
geben sondern anderweitig verwenden ist
nämlich nicht per se fettig sondern wir
wollen quasi das Kollagen wo von viel
drin ist dass das Ganze so gelieren
lässt dickflüssig macht mit in den Topf
bekommen aber das Fett eben nicht am
Ende fügen wir Fett in Form von Butter
für diesen seidigen Geschmack hinzu
jetzt geben wir das ganze erstmal rüber
in den Topf so wie es ist im Topf habe
ich ein klein wenig Olivenöl damit wir
auch das Gemüse mit anbraten können das
hat einfach so viel Geschmack und eine
gute Soße ihr werdet das am Ende von
diesem Video verstehen es wirklich
wertvoll ich nehme noch ein paar Knochen
raus wir wollen das ganze Gemüse ja auch
mit Kontaktfläche anschwitzen deshalb
lass ich erstmal ein paar Knochen drin
und gibt dann das ganze Gemüse dazu der
Lauch kommt erst etwas später weil der
wird bitter und so braten wir das ganze
jetzt ordentlich an jetzt gehen wir
unseren Lauch dazu und zwei Esslöffel
Tomaten wir nehmen jetzt unseren Rotwein
und löschen das Ganze ab erstmal ein
Drittel insgesamt ein halber Liter
jetzt lassen wir das Reduzieren
spätestens jetzt können wir auch die
anderen Knochen wieder hinzufügen unser
Rotwein ist größtenteils einreduziert
nach und nach Gießen wir den restlichen
Rotwein an jetzt gebe ich Wasser dazu
bis das ganze oben abgedeckt ist falls
ihr euch denken vor das ist mir schon
viel zu anstrengend viel zu aufwendig
weiß der Anfang also wir haben jetzt
etwa eine Stunde investiert das köchelt
allein vier Stunden jetzt erstmal
vertraut mir leider brauchen wir viel
viel Zeit jetzt decken wir das Ganze
einmal schön ab ist alles unter Wasser
ist und fügen unsere Gewürzen hinzu zwei
Lorbeerblätter Sternanis schwarzer
Pfeffer und Wacholderbeeren aufkochen
Deckel drauf vier Stunden köcheln das
hier vorne sind alles fett und Stoffe
die oben aufgeschwommen sind bei unserem
kalbsvorden seit bereits drei Stunden
köchelt ich nehme immer wieder mit einer
kleinen Kelle oder einem Löffel so ein
bisschen Fett von oben ab dadurch sparen
wir uns dass wir das einmal erkalten
lassen müssen und dann von oben
abschöpfen hier sind wir schon los
geworden es gibt natürlich noch weitere
Komponenten als die Soße so zum Beispiel
eine französische
Wort das heißt so viel wie klein
gehackte Pilze das ist überhaupt einfach
mal dafür habe ich hier drüben jede
Menge Champignons ein paar
Knoblauchzehen und zwei Schalotten das
hier hatte ich fein jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen ackern
[Musik]
ganz ist jetzt einmal schön durchgart
ich habe es gerade auch mit der Maschine
probiert jetzt mehr fast zu fein gemacht
jetzt machen wir einmal die Pfanne an
und jetzt kommt schon eine Sache die wir
uns überlegt haben ich glaube das gibt
so ein paar extra Punkte haltet euch
fest wir haben vom anrösten der
Kalbsknochen das Fett aufbewahrt und in
der Zwischenzeit im Kühlschrank
aushärten lassen und das werden wir
fortan nutzen wenn wir irgendwas
anbraten und kein Olivenöl kein nix
sondern wir nehmen wirklich das kalbfett
so dass wir wirklich so eine Runde
Nummer haben was genau diese duxel in
dem Gericht zu suchen hat also was die
Funktion von dieser pilzschicht ist weiß
gar nicht aber wir machen es gehört dazu
und meine Aufgabe ist ja heute dieses
Spiel Wellington so gut wie es mir geht
hin zu bekommen und Schalotten einmal in
die Pfanne wenn das ganze ein bisschen
angeschwitzt ist geben wir jetzt auch
die Champignon zu 500 Gramm waren das
insgesamt gehen wir einfach oben drauf
so soll das Ganze aus dieser
Küchenmaschine aus ihr seht schon den
Unterschied einmal selbst geschnitten
und schon so eine fertige Paste und ich
meine das wird eigentlich durch diesen
Schritt jetzt erst zu einer passte so
braten wir das jetzt bis die gesamte
Flüssigkeit aus den Champignons
entweicht ist wenn das ganze in Volumen
und somit auch in Flüssigkeit reduziert
ist nehmen wir uns einen guten Schluck
Whisky und schütten den Eimer oben drauf
löschen das Ganze ab damit ist dann
unsere düxel wenn das ganze ein bisschen
verkocht hat auch fertig und bildet eine
Schicht von unserem legendären beef
Wellington jetzt lesen wir die Knochen
aus unserem kalbsband heraus man sieht
schon wir haben ordentlich Wasser auch
nachgeschüttet immer zwischenzeitlich
nichtsdestotrotz ist das schon einiges
verkocht filtern wir die Essenz des
Geschmacks und ihr merkt das ist nicht
viel was wir hier aus der vielen langen
Arbeit bekommen haben hier haben wir das
Herz von unserem
also quasi das Herz von einem
Rinderfilet das edelste Stück vom Rind
und das seltenste Stück vom Rind auch
das macht wirklich luxuriösen Klassiker
hier ist noch ein bisschen was von
unserem kalbsfett und das Rinderfilet
seine schon immer so aus wir haben das
nämlich heute morgen erstmal kräftig
gesalzen von allen Seiten und dann den
Kühlschrank gestellt so dass das ein
bisschen oxidieren konnte auf jeden Fall
hat das natürlich eine schöne Farbe
bekommen wir wollen es ja auch wirklich
möglichst schön rund haben und so wie es
jetzt ist braten wir es einmal richtig
scharf an dafür ist unsere planscher
perfekt die mache ich einmal an richtig
heiß dann gehen wir etwas von unserem
kalbsfett drauf wenn das ordentlich
Hitze hat legen wir unser Rinderfilet
auf
und versiegeln ist von allen Seiten
dafür lassen wir es ganz kurz in Kontakt
so dass es wirklich schöne Röstaromen
entwickelt aber vor allem wie gesagt
versiegelt wir wollen das ist dann
später als geschlossenes Element in
unserem B vor linken garen kann
jetzt versiegeln wir noch die Enden
vegan tut es erst im Ofen während es
noch warm ist für Pinseln wir es einmal
mit ordentlich Senf das waren sehr
einfacher Schritt aber der ist schon mal
gelogen weiter geht's mit dem nächsten
ich habe jetzt zwei schnelle Crêpes
gebacken einfach mit Milch
daraus machen wir jetzt den ersten
Mantel dafür überlappe ich die so ein
bisschen und lege eine Basis aus
Schinken kannst du Parmaschinken
benutzen was auch immer das ist ein
luftgetrockneter Schinken vom gleichen
Metzger von dem ich auch das drinne
geholt habe das ist glaube ich alles ein
Stück weit auch dazu da so eine
Schutzschicht zu bilden damit genau das
nicht passiert mein letztes Lied bei
nach unten so da ist Flüssigkeit
ausgetreten und ein richtig gutes ist
halt geschlossen jetzt haben wir eine
wunderbare Basis auf welcher wir jetzt
die safe verteilen also das sieht
wirklich aus wie jetzt aus dem
Bilderbuch aus der Maschine nehmen wir
uns unser Rinderfilet und legen es
einmal mit ausreichend Platz hier auf
dann einfach drüber drehen langsam
konsistent nach vorne bewegen ohne ist
unser Crepe reißt durch den Zeitpunkt
dann auch den zweiten Crêpes mitnehmen
alles kompakt zusammenhalten alter
Schwede ist das ein Oschi na da würde
eigentlich noch ein bisschen fehlen ne
ich will dass das perfekt aussieht am
Ende ich sag nicht dass entlang des
Weges alles perfekt läuft es geht nur
darum dass es am Ende perfekt scheint
jetzt wieder zurückrollen nach schließen
so gehen wir das ganze jetzt in den
Kühlschrank für 20 30 Minuten so dass es
sich einfach normal setzen kann hier ist
unser Fonds oben drauf ist ein bisschen
Fett was jetzt durchaus kühlen noch mal
ausgehärtet ist fühlt sich jetzt ein
letztes Mal noch durch das Sieb hier
durch das reduzieren wir jetzt noch mal
auf 1/3 sollte ungefähr eine halbe
Stunde dauern und dann sollten wir wenn
alles gut gegangen ist eine schöne
Konsistenz haben die finalen Schritte
stehen an das Baby nennen wir es einfach
Baby weil mittlerweile habe ich eine
Beziehung dazu aufgebaut liegt im
Kühlschrank kühlt gerade noch Finale aus
ich habe mir noch mal extra großes Brett
genommen und hier halte ich blätterteig
in meinen Händen die verlinken wird
natürlich auch durch Blätterteig
ummantelt und wir haben jetzt ein
fertigen genommen weil Pizzateig dauert
ewig ist nicht unfassbar schwer aber wir
sind so schon seit mittlerweile sieben
Stunden sind wir schon beschäftigt wir
sind riesiges statuebriand haben
überlappe ich jetzt hier zweimal
Blätterteig und drückt das schon mal so
ein bisschen zusammen jetzt habe ich
einfach ein verquirtes Ei mit ein
bisschen Wasser das hier einmal in die
Mitte wo wir gleich das Baby platzieren
werden hier ist jetzt unser Wellington
halbe Stunde im Kühlschrank gewesen den
platziere ich jetzt hier an der
Hinterkante dass ich das ganze dann
einmal nach vorne rollen kann soweit die
Theorie ja du kleiner bleibst nicht
schön zusammen Alter hier drüben ist
schon perfekt wenn der Titel schwerstes
Gericht der Welt ist wirklich nicht
untertrieben ich habe jetzt die Seiten
so gut es gegen geschlossen abgesehen
vom Garpunkt von allem was jetzt noch
schief gehen kann oder insgesamt war das
hier meine aller aller aller aller
größte Sorge wir gehen mit ein bisschen
AdWords drüber auf Deutsch heißt das
Eier ich weiß gar nicht das zu sagen so
Leute habe da noch was für euch und zwar
ein
Roller wir werden ihn dafür verwenden
ein wunderschönes Gitter zu machen
welches wir über unser Leben dafür fahre
ich einfach von rechts mit ordentlich
Druck
nach links Schneide jetzt auch hier
einmal die Seite ab so dass auch hier
die Enden frei sind wir wirklich so ein
richtiges gitterding haben und dann
drücke ich alles noch mal an gleich
müssen wir alles im Ofen überlassen aber
davor überstreiche ich das ganze noch
ein weiteres Mal mit der Mischung das
dient der goldgelben Farbe und dem
anhaften für das Salz was wir gleich
noch drüber streuen und jetzt gehen wir
mit einem groben Salz dran weil das geht
noch mal wirklich so die extra
Prozentpunkte für die Optik das Rezept
Aufbau von Joshua weiß man sagt 205 Grad
25 Minuten wir haben so ein riesenoschi
dass ich bisschen runter gehe mit der
Temperatur 190 Grad und dementsprechend
30 35 Minuten das ist wirklich ein
riesen Poker weil der gab Punkt ist ja
augenscheinlich nicht zu erkennen mit
dem bloßen Auge wir gehen das jetzt in
den Ofen und hoffen auf das Beste guckt
euch jetzt mal bitte an wie wenig Soße
die nur noch übrig haben ihr habt das
gesehen dieser Riesentopf von heute
morgen alles nur für dieses kleine
schlückchensoße schön einfarbig der
Glanz kommt gleich durch die Butter
jetzt gehen wir auf unteres Drittel
Hitze es darf auf keinen Fall mehr
aufkochen und Rühren langsam aber sicher
Stückchen Butter ein nennt man Montieren
der gibt der Soße Glanz der macht die
noch ein bisschen dickflüssiger der ist
verdammt scary ob die Soße was geworden
ist wie unser beef Wellington aussieht
dafür müsst ihr noch ganz kurz warten
darf man sagen dass das wunderschön
aussieht
ein zwei Sachen haben wir heute Probleme
bereitet und zwar dass das so ein
riesiges Chateau war das hat es schwer
gemacht das einzuwickeln schwer gemacht
eigentlich alles damit zu machen aber
wir haben es jetzt hier und ich schiebe
es einmal auf die Arbeitsfläche ein
bisschen Feuchtigkeit haben wir auf
jeden Fall schon mal am Backpapier es
war auch ein bisschen was ausgetreten
vorhin wir gehen direkt in der Mitte
rein der Welt unserer
komplett auf eine Sache bin ich sehr
stolz die die XL ist auf jeden Fall
schön gleichmäßig außenrum von außen
haben wir eine perfekte Kruste es hat
nicht perfekt geschlossen man hat ja
gesehen mit anschneiden kam es wirklich
viel Saft raus und der Garpunkt ist für
mich ein bisschen zu hoch also ich mag
das nicht ich esse das gerne ist
überhaupt kein Problem ich habe alle
anderen auch dafür ist die Soße auf
jeden Fall etwas worauf man sehr stolz
sein kann glaube ich guck mal wie schön
die sich auf dem Teller verteilt schöner
Glanz fließt langsam wäre auch
langweilig wenn ich das jetzt perfekt
gemacht hätte oder also zum einen weil
woher soll ich so perfekt können so ich
habe mir echt Mühe gegeben so viel Zeit
genommen wie du irgendwie wie möglich
ich habe sehr viel gelernt über die
letzten zwei Jahre viel davon habe ich
hier angewendet aber der Geschmack ist
sowieso entscheiden und den testen wir
jetzt beef Wellington knapp 8 Stunden
also ein klassischen Arbeitstag hat es
mich gekostet dass hier vor mir auf den
Tisch zu bekommen ich habe schon gesagt
mit was ich vielleicht nicht ganz
zufrieden bin wir schneiden das Ganze
einmal an den süß ist vielleicht ein
bisschen vermessen die könnten noch ein
bisschen dunkler sein ein bisschen
klarer aber ich glaube das hier
entschuldigt an alles
krass ja so viel daran schmeckt richtig
es ist auf jeden Fall eher auf der
rareseite aber es ist trotzdem zart die
Jue hat es richtig in sich kann mir gut
vorstellen dass viele von euch sie
fragen lohnt sich das sollte man das
machen ich sage ja es lohnt sich Safe ja
das war wie verlinken das wahrscheinlich
schwierigste Gericht der Welt ich bin
auf jeden Fall zufrieden mit dem
Ergebnis egal ob es perfekt geworden ist
oder nicht ich habe es geschafft wir
haben es geschafft danke fürs zuschauen
wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder
bis dahin ciao